bonsoir j'ai mis cinq enfants au monde
et je me suis rendu compte très
rapidement que je m'étais trompé sympa
d'avoir mis les enfants au monde ni même
d'enfants d'ailleurs je me suis trompé
dans la façon que j'ai eue de les élever
parce que on vivait tous ensemble
évidemment dans notre famille et puis
régulièrement on avait des discussions
qui dégénéré en bataille et on three
tait et on allait on finissait par se
séparer chacun très triste et puis on
comprenait pas ce qui se passait puis
leur moi je me disais mais qu'est ce que
j'ai fait qu'est ce que j'ai dit pour
que ça dégénère comme ce à quoi je
comprenais pas en fait c'est quand avant
d'être maire j'étais une mère parfaite
je m'étais dit que en tout cas je serai
une mère parfaite que j'allais par faire
tout ce que mes parents avaient fait est
que j'allais élever mes enfants en leur
demandant un minimum d'obéissance bien
sûr avec autorité et que j'allais en
faire des enfants eux aussi parfait et
puis à un moment donné mes enfants plus
ils se sont rebellés
vous voyez ils ont commencé a pu être
d'accord du tout et alors là aujourd'hui
maintenant devant vous là je peux vous
dire merci mes enfants vous vous êtes
rebeller parce que grâce à votre
réveillon j'ai dû me remettre un peu en
question par un mort par amour pour eux
par amour pour vous je me suis remise en
question et quand j'ai commencé à
essayer de comprendre justement cette
histoire d'obéissance je me disais mais
comment encore voilà probablement que le
cema manière d'éduquer qui va pas quoi
et j'ai repensé ça peut paraître bizarre
je vais vous dire ça mais j'ai repensé à
une page de notre histoire au procès de
nuremberg gh
en fait je me suis souvenu
de ce procès où on avait demandé à tous
les dignitaires nazis qui étaient là
mais comment ça a pu être possible
comment est ce que vous avez pu faire
une chose pareille
à l'époque il fallait se remettre dans
les conditions de l'époque l'allemagne
nazie l'allemagne était un pays
extrêmement éduqués qui nous avait donné
en europe les plus grands poètes les
plus grands musiciens les plus grands
philosophes les plus grands écrivains
les plus grands médecins voilà c'était
un pays extrêmement éduqués et pourtant
il avait été capable de mettre au point
la solution finale quoi commence avait
pu être possible une chose pareille et
puis chez nous quand mes enfants étaient
petits il y avait il possède le procès
papon et je revois ce vieil homme au
moment de son procès tellement lucide
tellement intelligent on sentait
vraiment cette intelligence vive qu'il
avait ce monsieur jeu et on lui a posé
la même question comment est-ce que ça a
été possible une chose pareille et tous
ils ont tous répondu la même chose
ils ont dit on a obéi alors là je me
suis dit waouh ça veut donc dire que
l'obéissance ça déresponsabilise et puis
je vous ai dit en fait mes enfants ils
commençaient aussi à se rebeller et au
moment où je me demandais ce que
j'allais vous raconter ce soir comment
j'allais mettre en ordre tout ça c'était
le moment où il ya eu tellement de
manifestations en france il n'ya pas
très longtemps ça fait quelques jours
moi je viens de nantes et un an tu sais
pas vous imaginez vous avez vu ils ont
un peu casser un peu la ville coin on a
eu des enfants rebelles on a eu des
jeunes rebelles dans la ville et ces
jeunes là il nous disait la même chose
finalement
obéir à quelque chose qui leur paraît
autoritariste c'était insupportable
l'obéissance sacré ça aussi c'est à dire
que on prend sur soi on encaisse on
encaisse pendant un moment et puis voilà
on se soumet cette autorité là et puis à
un moment donné pour ça explose quoi on
n'en peut plus d'encaisser et c'est ce
qu'on a vécu un peu un emploi et c'est
ce que je voyais avec mes enfants alors
je me suis dit est ce que est ce que moi
j'avais envie d'avoir des enfants
obéissant docile soumis et en même temps
rebelles
non j'avais pas envie de ça j'avais
envie d'avoir des enfants
adapté et libre adaptée ça voulait dire
pour moi
des enfants qui compte qu'ils
comprennent aussi que pour vivre
ensemble il faut des règles bien sûr il
faut des lois et il faut des règles et
que c'est ça qui rend qui fait aussi
qu'y contribuer à l'harmonie et en même
temps libre à l'intérieur de ces règles
libre à l'intérieur de ces lois libre de
pouvoir dire oui de pouvoir dire non de
pouvoir s'engager si ça leur semblait
juste ou pas juste c'est de ça dont
j'avais besoin en vie alors je commence
à comprendre que plutôt que de fait que
d'être autoritaire et parfois même
autoritariste ce qui était probablement
plus juste c'est que j'incarne
l'autorité waouh
mais ça c'était un sacrément grands
programmes ça ça voulait dire d'abord
commencé par me connaître moi qui
j'étais moi quelles étaient mes valeurs
qu'est ce que j'avais envie de
d'incarner vraiment quel était le sens
de ma vie face à ouvrer voyez un champ
de questions alors je commence le
travail personnel et en même temps je
reprends les études et jeu est quand
même et quand quand ça commence à bouger
tout bouge autour de soi et j'ouvre un
cabinet de psychothérapie j'accompagne
des parents des enfants des adolescents
des instituteurs et des profs et je
m'aperçois vous savez on voit toujours
mieux c'était une j'imagine à l'adage
que vous connaissez bien
on voit toujours mieux l'ap la paille
dans l'oeil de son voisin que la poutre
dans le sien et je vois bien chez les
jeunes que je reçois là quelque chose
d'autres aussi qui découlent de
l'obéissance
c'est le vide de sens l'exemple qu'on
donne à nos enfants c'est pas toujours
un exemple très incroyable quoi
finalement la société qu'on leur propose
quelquefois et
ils se sentent impuissants devant ça à
quoi bon faire tout ça puisque
finalement toutes et tous pourris quoi
l'écologie c'est pourri à lui terrorisme
partout il y aura pas de boulot quand on
sera grand puis de toute façon à la
limite même s'il y avait du boulot
quelque part je suis pas assez bon pour
le faire alors ça marchera pas quoi et
alors ça me donne quelque chose de très
particulier qui s'appelle la dépression
nos gènes qui est la dépression du vide
de sens
la désobéissance s'amène à ça alors je
me dis vraiment moi ce que j'ai incarné
ce que j'ai vraiment envie d'incarner
est ce que je propose que je vais
proposer aux parts aux parents qui me
travaille avec moi d'incarner ça va être
la congruence la congruence soyez c'est
comme un maçon qui aurait son fil à
plomb qui va lui donner sa verticalité
la congruence c'est de travailler sa
propre verticalité ce le fait d'être
vertébrés soi même le fait de pouvoir
dire ok je sais qui je suis je connais
mes valeurs je sais ce que j'ai envie de
dire et je sais ce que je vais incarner
dans ma vie de tous les jours je connais
l'exemple que je vais donner à ça c'est
pas toujours très facile parce que quand
mes enfants justement sont devenus
adolescents et qu' ils sont allés voir
leurs copains mais quelquefois vous
savez dans notre société consumériste
c'est il ya des choses qui sont simples
faciles c'est alors que quand on veut
incarner des valeurs il ya des valeurs
qui sont difficiles à apporter quoi
alors j'avais des enfants qui
quelquefois me disais wow mais non non
reprises préféré aller habiter chez
notre copain et même un jour j'ai
entendu une chose horrible j'ai entendu
mais moi je préférerais avoir elle comme
maire alors ça c'est dur et puisque je
je comprends autre chose en même temps
c'est que ok donc je l'avais quittée
l'idée que j'allais être parfaite comme
mr donc j'étais donc imparfaite donc
j'avais le droit de faire des erreurs
mais si je faisais des erreurs à ce
moment là il se passait quelque chose
et je m'en suis rendu compte un jour où
vous savez on avait donc décidé des
règles de vivre ensemble tous ensemble
avec les enfants et notamment le fait
que on n'avait pas de téléphone quand on
était à table parce que pour nous le
moment du repas c'est quelque chose qui
était privilégiée on avait donc décidé
de pas prendre le téléphone et puis un
jour enfin très rapidement après cette
décision là le téléphone a sonné pour
moi et c'était un coup de téléphone que
j'attendais que jugée moins très très
important alors j'ai répondu et mes
enfants ils m'ont dit ben ça va pas ça
si nous on répond toi tu réponds pas non
plus et donc ce que j'ai compris ce jour
là c'est que ok je pouvais faire des
erreurs mais qu'à ce moment là j'étais
passible des mêmes sanctions que celle
que je pose je posais mes enfants et
donc je me suis privé de téléphone
pendant plusieurs jours ils autrefois je
rentre dans la salle de bain et
j'imagine que je sais pas tous les
parents connaissent ça vous savez vous
rentrez dans la salle de bain ils
vouvoyaient par terre les fringues est
allée du dernier qui s'est lavé avec la
serviette mouillée bien sûr par terre et
alors je rentre dans cette salle de bain
et là j'ai mon coeur fait un bon je me
dis que non c'est pas possible quoi donc
j'appelle le fils en question et je lui
dis coûte
voilà tu sais que ce qu'on avait décidé
ensemble à ça va peut-être ça va pas
être possible
il va y avoir une sanction à ce truc là
quoi et mon fils me regarde et on dit
est ce que tu veux bien te retourner
regarder derrière toi et là il y avait
tout mon maquillage sur le lavabo alors
nous avons été passible tous les deux de
la même sanction c'est à dire que quand
on laisser traîner nos affaires nous
mettions toutes nos affaires dans une
bassine que l'on pouvait récupérer le
dimanche suivant
donc je suis resté au naturel pendant
une semaine
aujourd'hui je me dis que j'accompagne
en fait les parents et est ce que je
peux voir parce que ça n'a pas été
facile c'était pas facile pour moi de
tenir ça et je voyais bien que pour les
parents autour de moi ce n'était pas
facile non plus
et je peux me dire aujourd'hui qu'il ya
trois raisons vraiment qu'ils sont
vraiment difficile aujourd'hui quand on
est parent la première c'est que nos
propres parents avaient un espèce de
piliers qui étaient pour beaucoup
d'entre eux en tout cas la religion avec
des principes un ordre divin qui était
établie et puis la notion du bien et du
mal qui était là alors que là aussi pour
beaucoup d'entre nous aujourd'hui c'est
plus tout à fait la même chose on a une
éthique personnelle et on se pose plutôt
la question du juste pas juste pas
simple ça la deuxième raison c'est que
auparavant aussi nos parents et le il
nous guide est dans un monde qu'ils
étaient certes plus grand qu'eux mais
qu'il maîtrisait à peu près il
connaissait à peu près ce monde et ils
nous en apprenait les codes et puis
aujourd'hui vous voyez de un couple un
papa que j'ai avec qui j'ai travaillé
avec son fils et voilà ce qui m'a
expliqué un jour tu comprends
aujourd'hui c'est bien compliqué parce
que aujourd'hui c'est nos enfants qui
nous apprennent ça s'appelle l'inversion
des lignes de transmission du savoir
alors comment faire autorité quand ce
sont nos enfants qui nous apprennent et
puis la troisième difficulté c'est que
souvent les seuls tellement seul dans ce
monde où notre notre notre travail nous
envoie aux quatre coins du monde
quelquefois est en tout cas aux quatre
coins de la france bien souvent et qu'on
est loin de nos familles loin de nos
racines
loin de ce qui pourrait nous aider à
être soutenus quoi on est tout seul bon
aujourd'hui j'ai un petit peu de recul
par rapport à ce que je propose dans
l'éducation
d'abord parce que moi même je suis grand
mère mes enfants sont grands et pendant
que je vous écrivais là aussi je reçoit
le coup de fil d'un patron du patron
d'un mes enfants qui me dit on parle de
certaines choses et puis un moment donné
il me dit vous savez vraiment ce qui est
vraiment chouette avec votre fils et
qu'il a des valeurs et qui les incarnent
et alors moi qui me posait la question
finalement qu'est ce que j'allais vous
dira peut-être ça m'a donné cette
légitimité de la wii en fait nos enfants
du coup il incarne ces valeurs là quoi
et les parents que j'ai suivi maintenant
j'ai suivi plusieurs milliers de parents
à travers toutes les conférences que je
peux donner les réponses et les mails
aussi que je reçois par rapport aux
livres que j'ai écrits ou alors les
ateliers où le travail en eau en
individuel en fait j'ai maintenant ça
paie plusieurs milliers de personnes que
j'ai suivi et me disent la même chose
qu'est ce que c'est chouette de savoir
qui on est qu'est ce qu'on a envie de
transmettre
qu'est ce que c'est chouette parce que
quand on fait ça souffle fort le vent
dehors quand nous nos enfants nous
bouscule quand nos enfants viennent nous
chercher dans les endroits qui sont
tellement sensibles pour nous alors
quand on est vertébrés quand on sait où
on va vraiment ça aide mais filles en
rentrant d'un de ses voyages m'a dit
maman tu c'est la plus belle chose que
tu nous les donner c'est que tu nous as
donné des racines et des ailes et je me
suis dit est-ce que je peux recevoir un
tel un tel cadeau alors que je me
sentais tellement souvent une mère une
piètre mère quoi est ce que je comprends
c'est ça aussi dans ce qu'elle me dit
c'est tu sais je sais qui je suis je
suis libre à l'intérieur de du cadre que
tu nous as posé je suis libre de pouvoir
m'engager quand j'ai besoin je suis de
pouvoir dire oui de pouvoir dire non je
comprends ça dans ce qu'elle me dit et
je me dis que le siècle qui vient il a
besoin d'avoir nos jeunes d'avoir nos
enfants eux aussi enracinée eux aussi
avec du sens en ayant trouvé le sens de
leur vie en ayant en plus en cuivre
pouvant incarner leur valeur et en
pouvant voir de grands de dire de grand
oui et de grands noms dans le siècle qui
vient
merci